hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
July 3rd everybody happy [__] July
4th hey British people take that one you
[__] Independence Day
you sons of [__]
we had enough of your [__]
and on July 4th we [__] wrote
something we probably wrote it on the
third
you probably wrote it on the third we're
like do you think this sounds good I
don't know I don't think there's enough
signatures [__] it let's do it and we
were like [__] you guys man
you think you know about oppression
we'll show you oppression
we're [__] go on a goddamn tear we'll
go on a [__] tear that will put the
British Empire to shame we still haven't
caught up with you
because when you go around the world
and whenever you see whenever you go to
a country and you see two groups of
people that are from that country at war
with each other
divided
your best bet is that the British were
there at some point in their history
foreign
we'll treat these people a little bit
better than those people they'll [__]
sell out and when we finally leave this
place they'll [__] murder each other
yeah
cup of tea in it
um
yeah we learned from you
that's what we are all you [__]
British [__]
who [__] sit here and you trash
Americans oh they're fat they breathe
through their mouths they [__] don't
understand football
you know they wouldn't know fish and
chip they don't [__] travel all of
this [__] that you say just no just know
okay your blood is coursing through our
veins
we are your children and you did not do
a good job raising us so you have no one
to blame
but yourselves
looking down your pointy English noses
at us girl Roy what's without a guns
over there mate what the [__] it's like
oh read a [__] history book you dumb
[__]
you brought the gun your people brought
the guns over here and [__] you know
went to town on the people that were
here and then
you started doing it to the [__]
pointy nose English people that you sent
over here they had enough and they went
your separate ways like the two brothers
that started that were uh worked at the
Zildjian Factory
right you guys are Zildjian we're Sabian
but we're part of the same [__]
family that's what it is
and you don't want to admit it now all
these centuries later you're disowning
your own children right what's wrong
with you people
bunch of silly [__] yeah now
now
you showed us how to behave with other
human beings and that's what we've been
doing
all right and what's great about America
is also why there's so many guns is
because everybody comes over here nobody
trusts anybody
you know and you just keep breaking it
down and breaking it down and breaking
it down and finding new reasons not to
trust one another
you know I'm white you're black I'm from
this town you're from that town you're
from that street I'm from this street
you're from across the street yeah my
[__] next door and you live upstairs
I live downstairs it never ends
you're a Polish I'm Italian it never
[__] ends that's why we have the best
movies
right because when you go to the movies
what you want to really see as much as
they dress them up in different periods
at the end of the day you want to see
them shooting at each other driving cars
really fast down the [__] Street
that's why we have better movies do you
ever think British people if you [__]
did more murdering of each other your
movies wouldn't be so [__] boring
you could never do Fast and Furious over
there be a bunch of [__] pasty [__]
on scooters going about 30 miles an hour
or whatever that translates into
kilograms
[Laughter]
uh you know I was at the airport the
other day and I saw this [__] mouth
breathing more on that you know we can
vote and you know he thinks he's smart
he had a t-shirt on
that said God Guns and guts
and I felt like I was on a game show my
answer was going to be are the three
things that ruin a peaceful Society
huh religion guts is a lot of times dumb
people thinking they're right and then
you give them guns and then you have
some other [__] [__] that's taking
their money every Sunday tell them that
God loves them best and next thing you
know you got a war or a genocide or
[__] slavery right and I know what
all you guns guts and [__] God people
are gonna say
yeah
how did it start
Right started with God and religion
right and then they had the guts to say
that they were [__] better than other
people
and then they got some guns and they
took them and next thing you know you
had human beings sticking other human
beings into [__] ovens while they
were still alive all right I mean what
are we doing here
I I actually I got to be honest with you
when I see somebody that has a [__]
t-shirt on that says God Guns and guts
you know that the second a dog a little
dog barks when they're walking down the
street at night they pee down their leg
a little bit
you know what I mean any of these
[__] people you gotta walk around and
advertise how [__] badass you are
that's like these liberal [__] out here
that walk around with sweatshirts on
that say namaste on them that just means
you're a selfish [__] that takes no
responsibility for your own actions stop
[__] advertising you know all those
other [__] [__]
that were out here on the red carpet you
know when the [__] hit the fan
and women finally started calling guys
out for grabbing their [__] around
[__] underneath the Hollywood sign
right then all of a sudden all of these
[__] [__] guys started when they
would go to the award shows they started
having male feminist
male feminist buttons
why do you got to advertise it shouldn't
the woman be able to sense that you're
an ally or whatever that [__]
you know you wouldn't know this was a
three-day weekend would you
happy birthday to America
um let's bring up some good things about
America Cars movies
uh
women got beautiful women over here we
got a lot of great stuff got all kinds
of food over here
uh
um
you know other than that you know I I
don't know I'll tell you
um at least there's somewhere to drive
your Supercar if you buy one out here
you know
you can get out in the open spaces I was
just up in uh Lincoln California
named after Abraham Lincoln he was
actually born out there a lot of people
thought he was born in like Springfield
Illinois or some [__] like that it's
actually not true it's one of the big
misnomers it was just a big tourist
attraction to get people out there to
rub the nose of the statue and go get
themselves a horseshoe
what is the Horseshoe you asked you
[__]
British [__]
um
why am I coming down on the British I
don't know it's just it's a fun thing to
do
even though I like most of their music
right
except for that one band that thinks
they're [__] great
and they really only had like one good
album with two good songs on it and
everybody's like oh my God they're
[__] brilliant
I kept that deliberately vague because
that describes about [__] 50
British bands
I like all of them though
you know the first British band that I
really [__] got into
that could just never seem to stay
together was The Kinks
right
that's sort of like a uh a reoccurring
theme in British music his two brothers
get together they make one of the
sickest bands ever and then they just
can't get along and they never get back
together again Oasis
how could I forget them
today gonna be day gonna fall back to
you I [__] love them boy now
I don't believe that anybody
you know not only were they one of the
great bands of all time like those two
[__] guys are arguably two of the
best comedians
that uh that Brit never produced
they're like an as a stand-up comic to
listen to their interviews read them and
watch them it's annoying how [__]
funny they are
some of the [__] that's come out of
their mouths it's like Jesus Christ
that's [__] better than half the [__]
my act right now
I do this for a living this guy's just
bored in an interview
spitting out gems
um I'm just [__] with you British
people
you know you like my arrogance thinking
that you give a [__] thinking that
you're actually paying attention you'll
give a [__] soccer season
and I will continue to call it soccer
because you know that's a kind that's
kind of rebel I am you know think I give
a [__] I have no [__] to give
that's a big thing on on social media
now everybody talking about you know
I got no [__] left
that's another one if you don't give a
[__] do you really walk around talking
about how much you don't give a [__]
don't you just not give a [__] you would
not even give it a [__] enough to say
that you don't give a [__]
get on with the not give me that's what
got me in trouble with that Lady Gaga
concert with my wife and to this day
she categorically refuses to go to any
concert with me unless it's a band that
I like if it's something that she's into
I'll be like I'll check that out she's
like yeah no
[Music]
like my grandmother at the end of her
life I was trying to tell her to hang in
there she was almost 105 and she started
coming back again like Hulk Hogan that
third time when they go to drop his arm
and the arm stays up in the whole
[__] Arena he's coming back right my
grandmother was coming back and I was
like Grandma there you go you just
started eating you you know you stay
positive blah blah and she was on the
other on the phone she just went
yeah no
she had had enough
she had enough most people at the end of
their lives feel like oh my God it went
by so fast you lived what I learned you
lived to be over a hundred
and they already announced your name on
Good Morning America
you [__] you're like I'm good
I'm good
she my grandmother lived so long she she
had three sets of friends she outlived
two sets of friends
people of her generation she outlived
the Next Generation and then she hung
out with the old people of the following
generation and outlived most of them ah
Jesus
I gotta go
I'll finish this in a minute
I'll finish just in a minute Christ it's
[__] 12 hours later
it's even more than 12 hours later where
does the time go
um
Lord has happened to me in the last
probably 14 hours
you know since you're not going to
realize it because I just edit the thing
to you let me talk to you guys about the
magic of editing
I just went down and uh
I had to get the [__] the uh what do
you call it the the the the diesel
exhaust pipe cleaner for my truck
you know I was all nervous it's a diesel
engine oh Jesus there's this extra [__]
you got to do thank God it's not like
the old school one so he had to drive
around in like second gear for an hour
at 4 000 RPMs and try to blow all that
[__] out the back of the [__] truck
or the car
or the they whatever it is you drive now
it's just an additive
and people still [__] that up
it literally comes in a blue container
right next to where you put the gas in
is this other thing where you dump it in
right
Reservoir whatever the [__] you call it
ends blue it matches the container and
people still will unscrew it and put it
in where the gas goes and [__] up their
fuel injectors and their Valves and all
of that [__] will not make
not all freckles
my [__] truck it didn't even come
with [__] owner's manual
I gotta go on the internet and find out
all of this [__] it's unbelievable like
the complete like go [__] yourself you
figure it out
I blame Apple for that they're the kings
of that hey here's this new device good
luck to you
we'll put a little video on there you
know
do you want to click on learn it'll have
maybe eight percent of the information
that you can [__] take unless you
just have you know
I don't know
if you're just naturally good at these
[__] things like anybody born after
the eight like the year like 1990 just
seems like they're like
they're like half a computer
like I [__] I posted a video
literally asking you guys for help to
figure out how to [__] buy a song on
iTunes now I don't know what they did I
don't know why they did it
I'm one of the few jerk-offs oh there's
plenty of jerk-offs but I'm one of the
few let me finish
let me finish before you say hey Bill
wait a minute okay don't get all [__]
you know up in your ego and think you're
one of the few the last remaining jerk
offs let me tell you something there are
plenty of jerk offs left
um I realize that
I run into them every day jerk-offs
[__] jerk-offs could have done it the
right way could have just been cool
could it not said the thing but they
can't
because they're jerk-offs
I am one of the few jerk-offs left that
still pays for every [__] song
you know essentially that I listen to
occasionally
I'll I'll uh I'll listen to a song
but if I you know I I won't buy because
I I just don't like it
all right there's no second date I'm
sorry
okay I hope you enjoyed the free meal
oh well though
I went out with you when you were you
were a douche
okay and I lost money in The Exchange
you on the other hand got to act like a
douche and get a [__] free meal out
of it and a free car ride so I don't
know what you're complaining about
hypothetical lady in my head right now
uh take me
to Siberia
in the coldest weather of the winter
months winter time do dude and it would
be just like spring in California as
long as I knew you were mine I've been
trying to [__] download that George
Jones song
for a week cannot
figure out how to do it all right
no mountain to rugged to climb no desert
to Barren to cross
um
[__] George Jones
they don't make them like that anymore
uh
yes they do
that's part of being old yeah I don't
[__] do it like that anymore
like I lived in some golden age of God
trying extra hard when he made people
you know let's be honest the guy's
slacking a lot he slacks a lot in every
generation it's why there's terms like
[__] jerk-offs sociopaths narcissists
and all that that's that's all
you know it's all part of his work not
every canvas is going to be a
masterpiece all right but he's God so he
never runs out of paint does he
well well he invented the paint
Praise Jesus I never understood that
when they talk about God and then they
bring up his son
you know what I mean like if you were a
fan of Joe Biden you would be like you
know Joe Biden you know he's actually
doing a good job
with the economy praise Hunter
foreign
dude that's something there's some
Jeopardy
there is some Jeopardy [__] trivia
for you naming
a president
a president's kids
the only way you know
president's relatives is if they [__] up
right
like I'll do it right now
I do remember Amy Carter
because she was roughly my age
when she was in the White House
right Amy Carter I remember
and then there there was
Billy Carter right there's always a
billy [__] it up
Billy Carter
Billy Clinton
right Billy Bush there's always somebody
named Billy that like this you know
somebody accomplished something it's
it's going along smoothly and next thing
you know what is Billy doing oh and I
was Roger
Roger Clinton
one of the the most trenched things I
ever saw was when the Letterman program
had him come on and sing walking the dog
he was trying to launch a [__] music
career
man that must have sucked for him
he's out there she broke a needle now
she don't so walking the dog and he was
doing some little [__] little shimmy
sham Shimmy Shimmy Shake [__] little
dance with his goddamn loafers
oh it was Bill Clinton
oh that was the weird one it actually
flipped maybe Roger was cool but somehow
we got to jerk off and [__]
hey say what you want about that guy we
[__] actually had a surplus there was
a moment in time where he actually had
we had more money
than we needed
and the dollar was [__] strong and
then then we got into a never-ending
[__] war that is still continuing on
that's costing us a [__] zillion
dollars a day
you know
maxing out the credit cards like
somebody's third wife
um what's the end game I don't know I do
not know
um
that must have sucked for Roger Clinton
where it's like all right let me get
this straight
my brother's president
and you know but I'm the musician in the
family right I'm out here singing some
[__] Aerosmith's covers of their
covers
right maybe I can get a little
a little side push nope
Oh Billy Clinton's got to go and [__]
uh go play the saxophone on Arsenio Hall
it was a double double whammy double
whammy
he did the music thing and he did it on
Arsenio and black people thought he was
cool and then what's Roger comes out and
tries to follow it up going on Letterman
and singing walking the dog it's out
there it's out there on YouTube if you
want to see it
I challenge you to get to get through it
and everyone in the show is just clearly
laughing at the guy it was [__]
brutal I always look at it like that
like look if you don't [__] respect
somebody just don't have them show up
like that movie where the chick goes to
the prom and they vote they voted it
where
I always forget the name was it carry
that was the only thing missing from
that performance was they should have
just dumped Pig blood on them in the end
pink dress when he went out there all
right so let's go through the billies
all right there was Billy Kilmer
who's one of the great quarterbacks of
all time
all right he put respect on my name
all right
and I was I was in the first grade I was
walking around I was feeling it then
Along Came Billy Carter
one of the
big jerk offs
of all time
I think he just couldn't handle the
pressure of being Jimmy's Brother
Jimmy's one of the great human beings of
all time
the guy's almost 100 years old I think
he finally
stopped Building Homes
houses for the homeless you [__] wait
you wait when that guy passes away
and people actually finally give that
guy the [__] accolades I'll never
forget that guy was President he was
considered a weak president because he
didn't let these [__] warmongers talk
him into bombing Iran
and he kept us out of the [__] War he
got the hostages back those [__] just
waited until Reagan came in office so it
would make uh Carter look bad
and all those [__] red ties of blue
ties every one of them sense him you
know they [__] the second they're
done being president they go out on this
speech tour I'm gonna go and give some
speeches for 300 Grand a night to these
corporations
that got him in office and then they go
out and give a speech and they pay him
300 Grand they just totally them washing
their bribe money so they can go buy
some big [__] house in Martha's
Vineyard some [__] aquifers down in
South America and meanwhile Jimmy Carter
continue to serve the public
and did nothing but help those in need
the guy is an absolute Saint so what's
what it what did his brother do
he came up with something called Billy
beer
you know
his brother's out there doing doing his
best to save the [__] world and stop
the industrial military complex and his
brother just was just say y'all want to
get drunk
I got some beer what's it called Billy
it's called Billy bear
there is alliteration
um
it's actually not worth a little bit of
money people actually have unopened cans
of Billy beer for the last [__]
I don't know what that would be almost
50 years
telling you right now someday this 12
ounce can of [__] deer piss is gonna
be worth money someday and you know what
I'm not gonna lie to you I went on the
internet just to [__] look at it
I didn't buy it
who else Billy the Kid
I always wait it was Billy the Kid that
was Billy Kilmer
it's Billy D Williams
okay yeah right as it was coming back
he's playing Lando Calrissian
that [__] Billy Carter's got to go in
and come out with a stupid beer
and then Roger Clinton acted like such a
jerk off that I actually thought his
name was Billy I got low self-esteem
here
with my name I got I gotta turn it
around
did I tell you guys I bought some new
symbols
I didn't buy something I got hooked up I
I already told you I got hooked up with
some new symbols and you know what I sat
down
yesterday and I finally got to sit down
and play with them and I gotta be honest
with you I still suck just as bad it was
very disheartening
I was like hey you know they got a dry
sound I'll put some white heads on the
on the toms and I'm gonna crank them up
have a completely different sound you
know what it just took me a minute
to kind of slide into something
different
well I'm gonna stick with
I'm gonna stick with it I'm gonna stick
with it like like Roger Clinton stuck
with this music career
um
sorry it's like literally like 5 30 in
the morning
and uh my son had one of those nights
where he just kept getting up
and kept getting up
and kept getting up I literally told him
I said listen
you stay in your bed you understand me
he's like yeah
all right this is it you're in bed he
goes okay I'm like all right and I gotta
walk out he goes
night night buddy all right
screams it
all right so I Leave the Room
I go down in the time it takes me
to leave his room
and walk into the kitchen
I look at the Monitor and he's already
out of the out of his bed
I run back down the hall I go into his
room he's not there he's in his sister's
room
and they're both in bed looking at the
iPad
it's like dude you're not gonna leave
your bed right yep yep okay okay dada
okay Dada second I leave just gets up
just takes off
um
and then he came walking into the room
last night at about I don't know two
three in the morning
he comes running down the hall you know
you know a a three-year-old runs
you know Boom Boom Boom Boom coming down
the hall and you're like sleeping and
you start having like a nightmare like
some [__] ax murderers coming in
burst in through the door
talking at two in the afternoon volume
so I had to put him to bed
again and he got up two more times and
then I just said [__] it at 5 30.
and I'm like
you know I'm not gonna have time to do
the podcast in the morning because they
because they're both going to be up but
you don't need to hear all of this [__]
you probably got kids yourself don't you
no no no
um
by the way I want to thank everybody
that came out to uh Lincoln California
Lincoln California
and um
came out to the shows I uh
I had such a great time
on both shows the crowds were amazing
and you know
[__] I just keep yawning sorry and I had
uh the last time I did that gig
um because they have a brand new
showroom
which was ridiculous I mean the way it
was set up um from what I've heard I've
never played Radio City Music Hall but
it's basically that style of venue
and um
the last time I did that gig they not
only did they not have that venue it was
an outdoor gig
and uh it was [__] like
90 95 100 degrees
you know both days that I was there
and uh so I was very thankful
that they uh that they had us inside
they treated me like a king I was up
there with Joe bartnick Joe bartnick
all right ATC we're gonna be putting out
uh before special comes out when we
putting out some teases some of his
jokes so
um
you know definitely check those out and
support the great Joe bartnick he's
going to be uh
headlining gigs around the country all
this fall and all of this summer if you
you know if you're one of these people
going like you know 88 you [__] you
can't do this anymore can't say that
anymore go see that guy and you realize
you know that you can what did I see the
other day where somebody was claiming
that
if this happened today people would
spontaneously combust and it's like that
is just such a misrepresentation of the
past
and the present
people always complained
people complain this whole [__]
[__] that My Generation generation x
is doing that nobody complained blah
blah blah blah and all of that type of
[__] I'll tell you it was it was
definitely much different and you were
definitely not
watched as a kid you were just sent
outside you did whatever the [__] you
wanted and that was it
um that part of it is true but that
whole thing that nobody complained is
not true
whatsoever people used to call up the
networks all the [__] time and they
would [__] moan and complain about any
stuff being too sexual stuff being too
dirty you know influencing the kids
they've always been doing those people
have always existed
all right it's just now it's easier to
do because you don't have to call up a
network you can just post it on a social
media page and anybody in the world can
[__] read it so it just seems like
there's a lot more of it but it's just
it's just simply not true that people
didn't get offended and people didn't
give a [__]
and you could [__] do whatever that's
that's never
been like you've never been able to do
whatever all the way back to the Salem
witch trials
all right
the the original time's up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the original [__] you know like if
you look at the Salem witch trial like
once again it was
it was something that no one could
disagree with we need to get these
witches out of our community now who the
[__] wants a witch in the community
nobody but the way they went about it
are you a witch no I'm not that meant oh
you know the if if you denied it it
meant you were a witch
and then if you admitted it then they
they still drowned you because you said
that you were a witch it was one of
those [__] things
it was the Catch-22 or whatever the hell
that expression is
um
there's always
been that
there's always been people complaining
there's always been people [__] you
know
everything that's going it's it's just
it's been going on for [__] ever so
don't don't listen to that
I even said you know George Jones you
know they don't make them like that
anymore they absolutely do there's
somebody out there that's exactly like
George Jones with a with a voice from
heaven with a major alcohol problem like
what do you mean they don't make that
guy anymore half the [__] my favorite
[__] rock stars are that guy and
they're dead
you know an incredible voice
a major substance abuse problem
although George got clean he got clean
and he turned it around
and this and you know there's people
like that now look at uh look at
Aerosmith look how many times those guys
have been in rehab now they're out on
their final tour I got to make sure I
swear to God if they come through LA and
I am on the [__] road
I mean that band
um
for the last like since since I bought
Aerosmith's greatest hits
you know when they when they were broken
up
after night in the ruts
and uh what was the next one
um when the lightning strikes
then they had greatest hits that was the
first that was the first album I ever
bought with my paper route money
remember was like seven dollars
something like that 6.45 I either went
to strawberries records and tapes or
Good Vibrations
trying to think the other one
um
I remember it was it was
it was all read with the white Aerosmith
logo like on half the cover and then the
other half was on the other side it
almost looked like the diver down
type of cover and
um
that added to like all the albums that I
had that my mother bought me which was
sing along with Mitch Miller in the gang
won't you come home Bill Bailey five
foot two lies are blue but oh what those
five foots could do has anybody seen my
gal that's what the [__] I was listening
to
Winchester Cathedral Lawrence Welk
um I kind of Stand by those records
though now when I listen to them because
they take them takes me back
um to when I was a kid
you know before all the [__] for all
the [__]
oh speaking of which I'm gonna be an
allen Allentown
Pennsylvania coming up and of course
anytime I get anywhere near
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
somebody a comedian from Pennsylvania or
one of uh one of the fans of the podcast
which I really appreciate will [__]
send me an email a text or whatever
and say hey I see that you're going to
be here you got to get a cheesesteak
from this place and I just
you know for the longest time I haven't
had the heart to tell them like I'm not
getting it
okay I've had the cheese take okay but
the thing is is I never had a
Cheesesteak until I was in my 30s so I
could see it for what it was
okay it's mostly bread it's it like if
you can tell me what cut of meat that is
from a [__] steer
um I I don't know what I I will give you
free tickets to a show
now and you can't [__] Google it
all right you have to know
okay and it's either cheese whiz which I
I don't even understand I don't even
[__] understand cheese was
okay then you got the cheese on top
endless okay I'm gonna tell you this
right now cheese whiz or the provolone
or whatever the sandwich
is [__] delicious
I will never argue that
as far as I am shit-faced or I [__]
just busted my ass for the first half of
the day
and I need to have a man lunch
you would be hard-pressed to find
anything better than a [__]
Cheesesteak okay I just tip my cap
to that in the sun risking old age spots
on top of my Charlie Brown head all
right but I will tell you this when you
get past the age of 37 you just you
cannot [__] eat that way anymore
every time I've had a [__]
Cheesesteak I've been like oh my God
oh my God that was so [__] good right
and then about eight minutes later I
feel like I ate a [__] Timberland
and I just I don't mind literally I fall
asleep like you my your body literally
shuts down and you have to go to sleep
because it's trying to process and sort
out whatever the [__] it is that you
just put in your body and it's just like
I finally
I don't know where I went the last time
oh I got a bad one and then uh I think
maybe the last time I was in Philly last
year I went and somebody told
recommended a place I went in there I
ate it and it sucked
the worst thing ever eating unhealthy
food that ends up not even being good
and you just [__] feel obligated
because you were raised not to waste
food that you plow your way through it
and it absolutely [__] sucked and
that it just cured me of it I was just
like all right I've had a Cheesesteak it
is a phenomenal sandwich all right
but is for a certain time in your life
okay it's it's for I would say 20s India
30s and it should be an occasional treat
in your 40s and when you're in your 50s
I'm 55 I can't eat that [__] anymore
I can't [__] do it
you know if I ever have a Philly
cheesesteak again you know where I'm
gonna be on death row
thank God they're gonna kill me anyway
I would try to time it too it's like all
right I'm gonna eat this thing but you
guys have to promise me that you're
gonna kill me in the next eight minutes
so I don't end my life in an electric
chair also being like oh God why did I
eat that
um
that happens to me when I when I go back
to uh to be
um even-handed here in Massachusetts
they have the steak and cheese
which they're all basically like
you know derivative of each other
I love a [__] steak and cheese
because I eat that unlike a a
Cheesesteak steak and cheese is a little
bit different I eat that thing
and it takes me back
you know taking me back
all the way back to like we know when I
was a teenager so I
love that thing right
but I have the exact same feeling eight
minutes later after I ate it I always
think why didn't I just split one with
my wife I just can't eat that way so
um
I'm back [__] working out
uh Billy elliptical
I've done the elliptical the last four
days in a row and if you think I'm not
getting on it today
doing my 40 minutes on yesterday I tried
to do 40 minutes and right around 32. my
my psoas on the left side started
getting a little tight and guess what I
did guess what I did I stopped
I got off and I stretched and I feel I I
listened to my body
I never do that I [__]
you know
that's what these kids do nowadays they
listen to their bodies oh you know I
didn't happen back in the 80s uh back in
the 80s you [__] your [__] way
shut up
I mean I know I'm guilty of doing that
[__] too there are some things that
[__] bother me
you know I'll tell you back in the 80s
if somebody gave you something they at
least gave you a [__] owner's manual
they weren't like hey you know you
figured out like the level of effort
that I'm having to try to [__] give
iTunes my Goddamn money I just love this
stupid thing like send us an email
but so a [__] robot can [__]
answer the damn thing
I like when you do that I mean a million
comedians have done a bit on it but like
the creepiness that they try to make
that recording when it's like if you
want this say that when you're just
talking to the the [__] thing uh uh
the recording
the robot the algorithm the jpeg
whatever the [__] it is on the other
side of the phone
and you just go I want a [__] person
and then the the [__] robot goes hmm
I'm having like it's thinking
don't say hmm like you're trying to
figure out don't [__] act like you're
as dumb as me so I can relate to you
you have the answers
you have them right at your [__]
metal fingertips all right let's do the
uh let's do the reads here
oh I didn't finish talking about the
elliptical uh my goal is I'm doing that
thing every single day in the month of
July do it with me
if you want to
do what I'm doing so I can feel secure
in what it is that I'm doing uh I'm
doing that this whole [__] month
and my goal is that I'm gonna have a
[__] flat stomach
uh for when my tour
gets going again
in uh in Massachusetts
right I got some gigs up in Maine I got
one up in Canada
you know what's [__] up I thought that
this weekend was my last weekend on the
road for a minute I thought I had three
weekends in a row evidently I don't I
have four in a row
I'm [__] in Tacoma again I don't know
why every time I go up to Seattle I go
to Tacoma now
I like Seattle I want to go into
Seattle
and you know what sucks is I didn't
realize that the MLB All-Star Game this
year was in Seattle
that's a city that my lovely wife has
always wanted to go to and I've always
said hey next time I go there I'll you
know I'll
I'll take you with me blah blah blah
we'll we'll you know watch them throw
the fish whatever you know get some
coffee
Jimi Hendrix
grave whatever whatever it is supposed
to do up there
am I nuts is Bruce Lee and Jimi Hendrix
both buried in Seattle
I mean that's pretty Epic
I'll tell you what's pretty epic he's
still saying something's epic and
[__] even even that sounded old to me
um anyway indochino uh looking sharp all
wedding season long shouldn't be
expensive
oh man that's another thing that's great
in your 20s a Cheesesteak and go into a
wedding when you're not the person
getting wet getting wetting getting
married
that's where all that's what it's all
about [__] open bye
you know
shooting fish you always hook up at a
wedding you just you just hook up at a
wedding
you know
women are taken away by the whole
Romance of the whole thing and they want
something themselves you know can't just
let their friend get married can't just
let it be her Knight
she's not gonna be the only one sucking
dick tonight
and no Chino
looking sharp all wedding season long
shouldn't be expensive with the custom
fitted suit from indochino you'll create
Priceless Memories without costing a
fortune I'll tell you right now there's
nothing better than a cheap suit that
that looks expensive
you know then you don't worry about
spilling drinks on it
you go out you make the sale
and then you hit the discotheque I love
to not laugh I got to a board game Sorry
showing my age on the Disco
oh yeah customize every detail on your
suit shirt dinner jacket
what are you in the [__] Illuminati
you got a rhino head on the back you
know you're [__] cool who the [__] is
a dinner jacket
I want a dinner jacket
you know what I almost bought the other
day I almost bought a [__] jumper a
onesie jumper at the Adidas store in
SoHo Manhattan
I almost bought one just for the joke
and I was just gonna [__] you know at
night you know after I smoke a cigar
take a shower and just come walking into
the bedroom wearing that thing and watch
my lovely wife laugh her ass off but
then I'd be okay
but then she laughs it's a one-time
thing and now I own a [__] onesie
like now what am I gonna do with it
you know give it to the homeless he's
already homeless does he need to be in a
onesie too
all right from a traditional black or
gray or burgundy or Olive to a classic
Hemsworth Navy
this is very Regal dinner jackets
Hemsworth Navy oh loving uh create a
suit that fits you and your style
perfectly with options for Fabrics lapel
shape custom monograms
there's some old school [__] you get
your initials on your on your shirt
collar statement Linings in more
they also have tuxedos starting at 579.
why rent when you could buy a custom tux
you can re-wear for years to come
indochino also offers completely custom
fitted shirts casual wear and more
they're always adding New pieces and
options so you can stay on Trend and in
style explore the relaxed yet refined
approach to Spring suits with their new
spring Fabrics RSVP knowing you've got
the perfect look all wedding season long
with indochino go to indochino.com use
the code Burr b-u-r-r to get 10 off any
purchase of 3.99 or more that's i n d o
c h i n o.com
indochino.com promo code Burr
oh my goodness
oh you look who it is
just when you thought the Knight
couldn't get any better it's all zip
you know if you're hiring you're
currently dealing with economic
uncertainty
and now more than ever it's important to
hire the right people faster and more
efficiently to keep overall costs down
thankfully there's a hiring partner who
is focused on you and your needs who is
it it's all zip
[Music]
from pricing to technology
everything that zip does is for you I do
it all for you
and what works best for you and right
now you can try them for free
that's it faster.com slash Burr here's
how ZipRecruiter prioritizes your need
straightforward pricing you know what
you pay before posting your job so you
can stick to your budget no surprises I
thought that was like you know but it
isn't it's you know what you pay before
posting your job it isn't you know
well you paid for before posting your
job I got all [__] up in that sentence
but you know what I'm saying beat out
the competition for talent
zip yeah
lets you invite candidates you really
want you really want to apply to your
job before other businesses can snag
them hire the best with the help of a
partner who's All About You zip
recruiter four to five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to this exclusive web address to try zip
recruiter for free ZIP
dot com slash Burr again that
ziprecruiter.com
spell out Burr
b-u-r-r how about I spell out recruiter
zip r-e-c-r-u-i
-t-e-r
all right before you end up on some porn
site zip recruiter zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh I love that
I I just just love sticking the landing
on that I really do all right let's get
to the uh let's get to the reads
for the week
farmlands
a billy blue
you're my boy blue
uh since you're always going on about
how [__] up the food supply is I
thought you should know if you don't
already that the Norwegian government is
forcing Farmers to shut down and sell
their Farms to meet National carbon
emission standards
whoa wait wait what they're using global
warming as an excuse to take over the
food supply is that what's going on here
carbon emissions is the scam they're
using to tax ordinary citizens for
essentially existing yeah exactly
that's what they're doing they're
blaming us for global warming not the
whole insanity
of capitalism
which I feel like we're coming to the
end of
where they've just you know
how many [__] things can you buy it's
just this empty [__] Pursuit
um
I don't know I I don't know this you
know what no no form of government works
because people run it and people are
inherently flawed so it's all designed
to fail yeah in the future they're not
going to penalize companies for their
carbon footprint they're gonna they're
gonna penalize you
so then what then you buy less
which will then cause a [__]
recession the whole thing's going to
just implode like a submersible
carbon emissions is the scam they're
using to tax ordinary citizens for
essentially existing while polluting
oceans and creating vast amounts of
weight with their needless products both
of which do far worse to the environment
than having a goddamn farm when I say
they I'm referring to non-government
organizations that spend hundreds of
millions of dollars to Lobby the
government to pass laws in their favor
yeah they're absolutely [__] evil
people that should be hunted down
and nothing happens to them because it
all works it's all about money
g bill wow what a deep Theory you stupid
[__] uh
the average citizen isn't sitting around
thinking that choking the food supply is
a good idea I'm pro-environment all the
way I do lots of things to not be ways
to be a wasteful [__] but shutting
down Farms sounds a bit evil to me
anyways thanks for all the laughs yeah
I don't know what their [__] end game
is but um
all of this like super frightening [__]
is happening
and then just
you know anybody that's actually in
power that can do it does not talk about
it the only people that talk about it
are [__] Meatheads like me on
podcasts with no power and nothing to
organize and no way to hold anybody
accountable one meat head just goes like
dude
and then the other guy goes I know right
laughs
all right next video all right old
school Atlantic City recommendations
oh what a [__] sweetheart by the way
that was one of my favorite things about
going when I went to Lincoln Nebraska
what Lincoln Nebraska Lincoln California
is uh flashback to my college days
um
is I went into town
and
and just scored everywhere that I went
I went in town I got some coffee
at this [__] place oh Jesus what the
hell was it called I gotta get the name
of it I can't [__] it up because it was
delicious
absolutely delicious all right here we
go I'm gonna google it right now best
coffee
Lincoln
California
Lincoln California uh
where is it all right the 10 best oh
Rebel hen Cafe
I went there I was absolutely delicious
and then I was with club soda candy and
he's like do you want to go back to the
casino I'm like no you [__] 10 foot
goof
let's go let's keep going in town and we
walked into town
and uh there was this great antique
store with this wonderful
great grandmother running the thing I
know she was a great grandmother because
at some point her daughter came in with
her granddaughter
and uh which was adorable they had all
of this cool [__] in there
uh there was a gun store but that was
yeah it was by appointment only
and then we went down the street and
there was uh
a place where I could buy a cigar
and um there was no taxi or Uber
available
you know for like a half hour so we just
sat there smoking cigars on this park
bench watching these logging trucks go
by
and just you know I felt like I was in
Andy Griffith in a good way
one of those small town things and I
feel like we went to four places maybe
not the Vape place but like the antique
place the gun store even though we
didn't get in
and the coffee place because it wasn't a
Starbucks I felt like we just like
it was reminding me back in the day of
when you traveled you traveled and you
actually saw different [__]
as opposed to you know the same [__]
corporate chains
um so anyway I love
um all of these cities that I'm going to
I have been to already and I've been to
them at least half a dozen times like I
don't know how many times I've been to
Atlantic City so the fact that somebody
is taking the [__] time to give me
some old school recommendations uh you
know I'm there for two days it's amazing
so
um if you guys can tell me the good
Coffee Spot
uh or a place that has you know
I don't know whatever the [__] a good
music store
old cars any [__] like that just cool
[__] [__] hey whatever the cool
[__] thing is that I'm not gonna see
anywhere else
as opposed to you know just seeing all
of those [__] fatties
and their Crocs standing in line outside
of a [__] Starbucks
you know
I love that fat culture morning coffee
you know because they just don't go in
and get the coffee they go in it looks
like a [__] shake and then they gotta
get like a muffin or like you know they
like they I don't know what I can't even
name half the desserts that are behind
that the glass
the [__] sconce I can't remember if
that's like a light that hangs on the
wall or a dessert one of those [__]
things something like that it sounds the
exact same right old school Atlantic
City recommendations hey Bill long time
listener and former resident of Atlantic
City I grew up in Atlantic City it's a
wacky town but it's inability to give up
on its Glory
uh Fly Me to the Moon Rat Pack days has
stunted the growth of the city leaving
it consistently in some sad purgatory
Jesus
I mean I don't think you could have
described it any better which to me is
what gives it its charm
see the great Bob ralphson movie Five
Easy Pieces with Jack Nicholson
Bruce Dern and Ellen you know what's so
funny I was just on Criterion last night
and I was like I want to watch that
movie
anyway I have some friends who live
there now who are really trying to make
the place better than it has been but
personally I like it the way it is uh
disorienting
disorientating and a little off hope I
said that word right I saw that you were
once again returning to the city and
wanted to give you a couple
recommendations if you were interested
as I know you appreciate history and old
things like me probably to to a
detriment no I love this [__] all right
Tony's Baltimore Grill Old School pizza
and Italian joint that's been around
since 1927 the new owner has
painstakingly refurbished the place back
to its earliest looks I'll do it come on
complete with red and black checkered
tiles cigarette machines and beautiful
neon signs this is a real old school
Towny place not the best food in the
world but it stands as a culmination of
atmosphere and authenticity the Irish
pub in
another old school joint around in some
fashion or another since 1910s the 1910s
uh
uh would you say that teens 19 teens
think Boardwalk Empire low ceilings
historic decor with much of it being
dedicated to old baseball memorabilia in
a sparse food venue featuring a liver
and onion sandwich Old School
Angelo's Fairmont Tavern another old
school joint since 1935 absolute classic
Italian food the steak and Jello Angelo
sorry Angelo steak Angelo is not to be
missed
I don't live there anymore and I can't
make it to the show but after a brief
weekend trip to see family and seeing
pictures of your red face
pimpled all across town on billboards
like a bad rash
I thought I'd steer you in some right
directions as I know Atlantic City is a
little written off as of late try the
last 30 years and we share some similar
interests that's all good to me another
good old school movie to check out is
Atlantic City with Bert Lancaster and
Susan Sarandon
Bert Lancaster how old was Susan
Sarandon like 15.
I feel like Susan Sarandon was like five
generations of actors after that anyway
thought you would appreciate these
joints if you have some time to kill I
hope to catch you down there some other
time but thanks for all the laughs and
go suck yourself
best
all right thanks for the recommendations
I'm going to write those down
uh
all right where are we going car fires
oh Jesus I had a car fire way back in
the day ever tell you that I tried to
change the fuel filter
on my Ford Ranger and I got impatient
I'd done it before and it wasn't coming
off and I got impatient and I ended up
breaking it off the fuel line
so I had to get it towed over to this
guy who've been working on the truck if
given it's a tune-up you know and I went
over there and I said to the guy I said
you know I snapped off the fuel filter
and I left the fuel filter on
the driver's seat
but my mistake was I should have really
made it clear to him that I did he was
busy and he went out there or whenever
they went up and they went to start it
up and it just sprayed fuel
onto the the uh
the engine and they had a fire and then
he called me up
and started yelling at me and I said
dude I told you I snapped it off he said
you said you twisted it
he kept I remember he just kept going we
just had fire
we just had a fire it's like no we
didn't you had a fire you [__]
[__] you sat on the fuel filter but
all these years later I can look back
and be I mean I didn't understand that
it was going to cause a fire this was
all when I was trying to be old Billy
fix it
um where I had car repair for dummies I
remember he did say seemed to me he goes
I'm so sick of you [__] guys you
start the jobs you [__] it up and then
you [__] bring it down to me so when
you could do [__] like this there was no
cameras
you know when you went in and you tried
to get your money back or try to get
some sort of customer service people act
like there was customer service back
then there wasn't
okay the owner of this shop came out
like some [__] like Earl Weaver out
of the Dugout and just yelled back at
you and you both told each other to go
[__] each other [__] each other right
[__] it [__] yourselves that's what we
would say uh hey go [__] each other who
you and me what what are we doing uh go
[__] yourself and there would be always
big kids there
and some poor woman sort of you know
corralling them out like trying to get
like a herded Ducks out of there all
right car fires
Bill how are you now uh long time
listener first time emailer I listened
to your mini rant on cars and fires the
other day I would like to shed a little
light on the subject as I work in fire
protection oh yeah because this is big
[__] thing out there where they're
all of a sudden attacking
like
um
electric cars and my favorite thing is
what they do to the environment like
people who like gas combustion cars are
all of a sudden concerned about the
environment people who drive gas
combustion cars combustion cars are all
of a sudden concerned about safety gas
combustion cars combustion cars the only
[__] people they killed
over the last hundred years as they work
the bugs out this is a new technology
this always happens if you have any form
of transportation and it's new people
are gonna [__] die and there's gonna
be fires the same way there was with the
gas combustion engine
so I don't know what like the the level
of fear that people have
you know and then the next thing they do
is they're going to bring up the
Republic of Congo and whatever the [__]
they're doing out there and how awful
that is while they look the other way
with what the [__] going on
you know
with how we get oil in this never-ending
[__] War it doesn't even make sense
I don't get it they're they're both like
both of them
the way we get the raw materials for
them is absolutely reprehensible and for
such a religious country like America
against God
if you're really religious all right
long time okay uh I attended a
conference last year that discussed this
issue lithium lithium ion batteries have
become a nightmare in our industry as of
late causing many design approach
uh and code changes no car fire is a
good thing but there is a big difference
between a combustion engine fire and
lithium ion powered car fires combustion
engines typically burn upwards and do
not spread to the car next to it
lithium ion batteries burn outward at a
much higher heat and spread to the car
next to it causing a larger fire
okay well do you remember when the uh
the Crown Victoria where they they put
the gas they put the [__] gas tank in
the wrong area and they when these cops
would be on the side of the road and get
rear-ended and they couldn't get out of
the car and they would get burned to
death like I don't want to hear all
these [__] like oogly boogly stories
about electric cars the reality is is
electric cars are here and they're
cutting into gas combustion engines so
then people have in the oil industry now
are going to have to put out all of this
[__]
propaganda about how they're going to
[__] kill our children this is what
they always [__] do I'm not saying
that this [__] doesn't happen I'm not
saying they're not a [__] problem
I believe those batteries have taken
down commercial airliners
and now they know don't put them
underneath the the plane or whatever
uh yes I am well aware that there is
danger with these things like there is
with any
form of Technology but they're going to
work the bugs out of it
they're just going to like I'm just so
sick of watching like like they'll show
like a uh
like a Tesla beat a gas combustion
engine and then people like can it go up
a mountain like what are you gonna do
out there when you're up on a [__] who
the [__] goes up on a mountain
laughs
yes if you're going to drive it up on a
mountain I wouldn't recommend it if
there's no charging facility up there
yes I would not recommend that however
if you're like other the other 99.9 of
people you're not going to drive it up a
[__] Mountain you're going to drive
it to work and home
anyway
um
lithium ion batteries burn outward at a
much higher heat and spread to the cars
next to it causing a larger fire the
heat that the lithium-ion battery causes
produce has been leading to garages
collapsing the amount of water required
to extinguish or now all of a sudden
we're concerned about natural resources
the amount of wire required to
extinguish a Lithium-Ion battery powered
car is far more that that of a
combustion engine sorry for nerding out
a bit new technology leads to newer
challenges we need to overcome exactly
this is the first rational thing yes any
new technology is going to have these
[__] problems as the car industry
continues I mean there's aren't there
lithium ion uh [__] batteries in your
goddamn laptop
aren't there couldn't it burn down your
house but people want to watch free
[__] porn so no one gives a [__]
about that right uh new technology leads
to newer challenges we need to overcome
as the car industry continues to
progress the studies and concerns of
these issues will be addressed okay I
didn't okay so you're rational you're
not one of these [__] Witch Hunt
people lastly paper Tiger has to be one
of my top three stand-up specials of all
time oh thank you so much
thank you so much well you put out
enough specials eventually someone's
gonna like one of them Bill why can't
you just take the compliment
because I grew up in the 80s man there
were no compliments all right
not your average mouth breathing [__]
all right Bill big fan of your work
always laughed a lot when you would call
out the mouth breathing morons on the
podcast until last year
I realized
that I also do that
so I thought that that can't be right
went to an ENT doctor found out what was
wrong and had an operation which now
allows me to breathe like a normal human
being thanks but wait what happened
laughed always laughed out loud when you
would call out the mouth breathing ones
in the park until last year
oh I realize that I also do that meaning
breathe through your mouth
I thought you meant you called out mouth
breathing morons
wait a minute so what
what operation did you have
do you have like that flap in the back
of your mouth like a bulldog and you
couldn't breathe
anyway
on one of the last
latest throwback podcast you talked
about how much you love Moments in
Sports when players react to an [__]
in the crowd
oh speaking of that
I just saw this clip from like
the late 70s mid 70s late 70s
put it this way Robert Parish is on the
Golden State Warriors
or maybe San Francisco Warriors and I
think they was called Golden State yeah
they were Golden State in the 70s and ml
Carr was on the Detroit Pistons before
they both came to Boston
through shrewd red Arabic trades and won
championships and it was a [__]
unbelievable fight that spilled into the
stands and
somebody threw a beer at somebody and
Bob Lanier
[__] you know
was fighting someone in the crowd and I
gotta and if that was an away game
for Golden State that was the second
time you know when when malice in the
palace
you know that one that happened in uh
Detroit I think that's happened twice I
posted the video
um anyway the person says on one of your
latest throwback podcasts you talked
about how you love Moments in Sports
when players react to an [__] in the
crowd well here is Eric cantones one of
the coolest soccer players ever reaction
to some fan telling him to [__] off back
to France you French bastard hope you
enjoy
all right
there's a [__] old ass looking ref
there's a referee Roy
he's had his mushy peas
oh Jesus Christ oh number seven
oh Jesus Christ you know what he did he
jumped up in the air and and threw a
kick with his cleats
soccer players it's just like did he
think he was going to get a penalty if
he used his hands and punched him in the
face
um okay flying from London to see you
but I mean I'm sure that hurts the way
those guys roll around when they get
[__] clawed by those things
um flying from London to see you in
Athens get the [__] out of here in
September
so don't get [__] ill or something
thank you and go [__] yourself that's
amazing but let's who's kidding who
you leave in [__] rainy ass London to
go to beautiful Athens and oh by the way
you'll check me out you go to the
Mediterranean Sea I'm really happy for
you that's amazing
um
War London tell make me laugh
every shot with a long face
um
sorry all right that's it that's right I
am going to be an Athens I start the
tour in Abu Dhabi and I end in Athens
it's going to be [__] amazing and I'm
gonna be in shape all right I'm not
going to be the Fat American when I go
over there I am [__] Billy political
from here until then uh I just gotta
make sure I drink enough [__] water
all right that's it uh thank you guys
for uh listening to the podcast go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you
on Thursday